so I'm dancing with mine that is the
song eyes closed off of Ed Sheeran's
brand new album subtract which was
released overnight and he's got a lot to
celebrate right now the singer
songwriter won a major Court Victory
yesterday after a long legal battle over
one of his most popular songs a federal
jury decided that Sharon did not steal
key elements of Marvin Gaye's 1973 song
Let's Get It On to create his
grammy-winning hit thinking out loud
I'm obviously very happy with the
outcome of the case and it looks like
I'm not having to retire from my day job
after all that was Ed Sheeran after the
Manhattan jury in his copyright
infringement trial ruled in his favor
the case began in 2017 when The Heirs of
the late let's get it on co-writer Ed
Townsend filed a civil lawsuit against
Sheeran alleging he ripped his pop hit
Thinking Out Loud from Marvin Gaye's
Soul classic listen for yourself
[Music]
I will be loving you
till we're 70.
Sheeran spoke about the lawsuit with our
Seth Doane for CBS Sunday morning before
the verdict and said the song's
similarities are just a fact of the
music industry it's full chords that get
used in pop songs and there's however
many notes eight notes or whatever and
there's sixty thousand songs released
every single day you are going to get
this with every single pop song from now
on like unless it just stops which I
don't think it does because it's a big
money business to take things to court
it's clearly a Charged topic every
single musician you speak to will agree
with me every single one you can only
get caught out if you've done something
wrong and I'm not I have not done
something wrong I'm not lying here I
used four chords that are very common
chords to use
and they sound like lots of songs it
just it rolls me up man it right it
rolls me up and I've I'm never allowed
to say anything
but there's so much to say
I love that you can watch it Seth Jones
full interview with Ed Sheeran this
weekend on CBS Sunday Morning big win
yeah YouTube is something it went for
music over all the way he presents it
yeah I mean you know first of all
remember that this has been going on for
many years yeah 2017 so imagine having
to deal with this and then show up in
court but what she did to defend his
songwriting process yeah he's clearly
very angry about it and he's never
wavered on his on his feeling about this
yeah and when he said I will give up my
music career if I lose he was so sure
that he was on the right side of history
with this but you never know where the
jury though you also got to see the
other side too they say beauty is in the
eye of the beholder the sound of the
song goes in the air of the musicians
that's absolutely right and the jury but
you're right yeah the jury said you know
he didn't do it